hey i'm alexis hi i'm alex and today
we're gonna watch our first episode of i
draw you cook together i'm excited to
watch this one me too i'm glad we're
doing it together yeah
let's watch us
hi i'm carter and i'm drew we're seven
years old and today we're going to have
two sets complete to make oh my god my
hair this one
oh i remember this
i'm alexis and i'm alex okay i just have
to take chairs okay this damn tiny
chairs and my hair was so
short i get dms like every week being
like bring the short hair back we missed
our hair and i was like no i love your
hair both but thank you my hair is the
same so yeah no it just changed bad
dragon eats me so that's what he's
trying to get but they're good i feel
like what was so hard about this one was
the fact that there were two of them and
yeah they were just like on totally
different never again not only is like
with one kid it's hard enough then two
it's like double the craziness like i
think after we shot this we went to the
producer and we're like never again yeah
oh my hair looks rough
you guys draw it for us yes what's this
pink you're drawing oh
the evil stuff while they're talking i
look at alexis
and i'm like
that look was like help
what do we do
six eyes hi if you look at us like our
faces look at the faces our faces look
so unhappy cute so i'm really going to
try to incorporate that into my i need a
brush
here we go do you know what those taste
like um they like taste like like a meat
bar meat bar
what are your favorite vegetables uh
broccoli
broccoli i think drew and carter are the
only kids i've ever met that actually
like broccoli and not just like it but
love it
how did you know if they were lying
that's the tricky thing with this show
is that you never know
and they're liars do not do not trust
them they are unfortunately not to win
let's go make some magic okay
[Music]
i
we were like trying to do those like
magic tricks this whole time we were so
corny but and like it i love it it's so
funny we have to do that like a million
times though to get it the right timing
so here's my plan for the body of my
dragon i'm going to use a giant chicken
nugget it's honestly it's brilliant it's
brilliant so purple and green for the
wings i'm going to make burger patties
why don't they make them black it's so
weird i don't know the drawings are a
nice touch for the show they are
i was very literal you were literal did
i put pineapple
you did
wings
out of like a maple bacon yeah this was
really good
this was when i saw you i was like god
damn she's gonna win
okay i was i was really proud of myself
this was really cool so i'm gonna start
with my giant chicken nugget it
unfortunately does look like cat food
right now oh oh i
that was
we're able to be silly because you have
to be when you're making crazy stuff
it's so
well
that i'm sorry it doesn't look good what
did i do i feel like i feel like the joy
of the show too is like you get really
creative in ways that you wouldn't
normally
and sometimes i look back and i'm like
whoa you have such a short amount of
time that you kind of just gotta do it
yeah and i think that's big with like
creativity in general
doing it first do a little bit of a dry
coating in this flower
this is genius of you honestly
that around just a giant
wow this was so long ago i know
you look like a different person you
literally look like it i look like i'm
looking at a different person my chicken
nugget looks pretty good it's golden
heart same heart
i had this crazy idea to
try to dye the cheese for oh my god
it looks so intense listen i just
kids like color food coloring cheese is
not that weird have you ever cooked for
kids no
i have not you haven't i mean like on
the show this show is because i used to
be an au pair so i am really used to
taking care of kids i haven't
you know still lost this episode though
i'm just going to put my barbecue sauce
in a squeeze bottle so that
do you think it was like that it was so
funny or that was so delirious i feel
like the thing is that people don't know
is that it's like 90 degrees and there
you have like all these cameras and
lights you're cooking you have like a
short amount of time you're like making
this crazy face you're doing so many
different things and so i feel like it
was really funny but i think we were all
so delighted
and like this was almost at the end like
we've been cooking for hours
i got so genius to put it on the sheet
pan there wasn't a big enough tray no
idea which way this could go it was just
different because you you didn't stick
to the picture but you made something
cooler i like that we're going to react
to ourselves reacting making this
drawing i was really skeptical and
absolutely it looks insane
i feel really optimistic about it i
don't know i was like it's fine she's
gonna win it's fine but you never know
you never know with kids
i also am confident it looks great it
looks like the picture what's going on
but in my experience kids love all these
foods too so they do see that's the
thing i knew that that kids like those
kinds of foods totally it's definitely
not what they drew my hair looks insane
but your dish looks great this looks
great heirloom's problem my hair looks
crazy too
now let's hope it tastes like their
imagination yours looks like they're
just going to spot them that was just my
tactic this whole time
this is
potato
so when we first started filming the
scene
they were switched in the opposite
chairs and no one you noticed
i mean this is also the funny thing
about like working with i mean like kids
okay we want you to like say those same
things again
no you got to be vigilant
really who doesn't like mashed potatoes
and it doesn't really look like a dragon
but it looks good it looks just like our
picture it's really so it's so good it's
just broccoli oh in the middle it's a
chicken nugget is it just a christine
broccoli it was just yeah
it's keep it simple somewhere this head
that looks just like a dragon
i knew immediately i was like i'm out
this one like a lollipop candy thingy
it would be a little better without the
salt why did i try to make salted maple
candy you're very sophisticated
no you know what like what
that is an actual dragon fruit he's like
what is that dragon food
eating a dragon beast
it was it was a true dragon piece
alakazam
hello hi guys hi
two have two very different dishes which
did you like better the chicken nugget
or the i just always feel really nervous
why because you're like you don't know
who they're gonna pick i knew who were
they are gonna pick are you getting the
chicken nugget or the meatloaf
[Music]
i think the magic was in my favor this
time
that's so sweet
okay the like last second of my face and
that was like
we're down here
listen i wasn't even mad to lose to that
one because it was obvious we did
another one where i lost like terrorists
but it's so fun because it's all about
the journey it's about the journey i
feel like people like the show because
it's like you're making kids happy yeah
you get to have a lot of fun with it you
get to make something that no one would
expect or think to make i would never
serve an adult like you would never do
that a dragon meatloaf it's nice to have
like videos to look back on and to
remember i think we've come a long way
we have thank god
our hair our hair has come a long way
thank god